- A lot of people are throwing around
the word sedition recently,
and unfortunately not for no good reason.
But what is sedition itself?
Well, originally as used
in the United States,
sedition meant opposing or resisting
any law of the United States
or writing anything false,
malicious, or scandalous
about the president or Congress.
But because of the First
Amendment, that doesn't fly.
So now the law is codified at 18 USC 2384,
which makes it a crime
for two or more people
within the United States
to conspire to overthrow
or destroy by force the
government of the United States
or to levy war against them,
to oppose by force the authority
of the United States government,
or to take, seize, or possess by force
any property of the United States.
And the next statute makes it a crime
to advocate for the violent overthrow
of the United States government.
Is what we saw on January
6th actually sedition?
Well, I'm gonna do a
full video to find out,
so I'll see you in court.